[Music]
you'll take turns navigating the hmas
stem to its destination so it can
deliver its cargo to get it there safely
you'll need to avoid submerged obstacles
using your sonar screens
the challenge you're facing today is all
about sonar sonar stands for sound
navigation and ranging and it's what
allows us to try and navigate underwater
which is pretty difficult because it's
so dark down there now for us to
understand the underlying principles
today we want to know how to Stone our
work and particularly how does it
actually use mathematics to allow us to
see where we have no visibility now a
little metaphor that I love for this
which some of you will appreciate more
than others is that you can see I wear
glasses I rely on these to be able to
understand the world around me that's
because I have a short-sighted eye and a
long-sided eye so everything is kind of
blurry and fuzzy and Confused until I
put these glasses on now for me I kind
of think of these glasses the way I
think about mathematics it helps me see
the world more clearly understand it and
bring all of these patterns and
relationships into crisp Focus now
that's a nice metaphor right but
actually because I thinking about sonar
today this is really literal we
literally use mathematics to see what's
going on because underwater it is so
dark and there's so little we can see
we're actually going to use these
principles of sound and reflection to
know what's around us now we're going to
think about two different kinds of setup
but I want to give an illustration for
how this works and to do that even
though it's an illustration
I'd love you all to close your eyes now
we do a version of what sonar does close
your eyes now and I'm going to get you
to I'm going to test out how your sonar
works by moving around you and I'm going
to click my fingers as I walk and what I
want you to do is just listen hard
and how to think about where I am as I
move are you ready
here we go
all right you can open your eyes
now this will be easier for some of you
than others because of exactly where I
moved but I'm going to throw to all of
you where do you think I went
do like a little Loop a little a little
Loof okay I'm interested see Mac I think
it would have been hardest for you
because you were literally furthest from
me a loop is a good suggestion can you
give me any more detail about where that
Loop went you went in between tonight
and you went down there okay fantastic
so yes
um and there's not heaps of room to move
but yes that's exactly where I went
what's Wild is think about this right
without being able to see you could tell
Direction you could tell a little bit
about as well how far that I was you
know if I was even if um say for example
for you Sophie if you look in Liam's
direction right
that line between you right and going
actually going through you Liam right I
was along that line twice once when I
was behind Liam and then once when I was
in front of him between you two and you
could tell the difference between when
those were because you can hear I'm
louder I'm softer and also because we
have two ears the sound that's coming to
you actually comes to you twice once for
you left here once for your right ear
and that's actually how have you ever
done this before you've put on
headphones you've watched a video right
and in the video you can hear when the
characters on one side versus the other
no movement is happening it's all in
your headphones isn't that incredible
what your brain is doing to process all
those signals that's exactly what you're
going to be doing in today's challenge
as you navigate through this really
interesting space so going to teach you
a bit about this and there's two
different kinds of sonar that we're
going to talk about the first one is
called passive sonar now I want you to
think about all of your mathematics
about Direction you know how we were
talking about like where exactly did I
go okay I want you to imagine here's you
or the submarine that you're operating
and we can work out directions in terms
of bearings right so if we put sort of a
circle around you and we said okay in
front of you we're going to call that
zero degrees that's where we're going to
start okay so if we call this zero
that if we went clockwise around we
would say that this measurement that
bearing would be 99 degrees directly
behind you as it were would be 180 180
and then we finish over here I guess
with two 70 before we come back to 360
or zero where we started let's imagine
what happens as an object is stationary
and obstacle like the ones you're going
to have to navigate past and we go past
it right so let's suppose
it started up here and we're traveling
past it so kind of it looks like this in
time okay either we're traveling past it
or it's traveling past us doesn't really
matter okay now let's just put a few
markers of time in here things like that
all right now
it's going to start up here and then
we're going to experience it going past
this so how do we actually read where
that is remember we can't see it the
thing the viewer that I'm showing you
right now you don't actually have we're
kind of like
you know as if we're omnipotent we can
see everything that's going on here okay
we're going to measure bearings to this
object over time okay so let's just
imagine there's like one second between
each of these markings okay so first
we see it up there okay just eyeball it
what do you think as we go around this
dial what do you think that angle looks
like roughly
30 degrees Yeah I'd say it's kind of a
third the way around to 90 degrees so
let's call that 30.
okay and then it progresses as second
passes and then we're going to be
somewhere around here what does that
look like to you 45 45 I agree
this middle one is pretty easy I do we
deliberately put it so it's directly to
your right so we can call that 90
degrees already written
let's do another one over here so what
do you reckon that would measure as
um yeah I think it's about halfway
between 90 and 180 so let's call that
135 and then
a final one over here
there's kind of a symmetry there isn't
it Okay so we've just chosen some pretty
straightforward rough angles for
ourselves now what does that actually
look like on your sonar screen well what
you're going to read on your screen is
what we call a bearing rate graph and
we're going to try and take these angles
and put it onto something rectangular
it's actually pretty tricky to do so if
we put zero degrees here in the middle
see all these angles on the right hand
side we've got 90 degrees and then we've
got
180 degrees and what happens is we can
see where we are in relation to time
okay so we're going to put our time
markings down here now one two three
what that'll do okay so what's the first
thing that we saw we saw it around I'm
going to put a few markings here just to
make it a bit easier for us
we saw first angle of 30 degrees right
so the earliest in time is going to be
down from the bottom and we'll go
upwards okay so where's 30 degrees on
here I would say it's something like
that spot right there okay
next we saw 45s that's halfway that's
easy to Mark in so next time marker
something like that you came in there 90
degrees I'm going to go on to this
midline and then you can kind of see
where this is going can't you right so I
think we said 135 somewhere around here
and then 150 okay so what we're actually
going to be reading on this graph is
we're going to see this sort of steady
line like so and this is the thing you
see
this is what it means
but the mathematics has to be
interpreted you're like oh I look at the
bearing I look at the time what is this
object doing it's moving past me on my
right hand side
yeah okay I just have a quick question
so the line on the right that's the path
of the moving object if we're stationary
yeah that's exactly and it's like past
us like moving yeah so this was the
graph that we created when we know where
it's actually going which is moving past
us on our right hand side okay that
makes sense so literally this is what we
see on the screen and we interpret that
as this is what it's doing over time
okay this is the earliest and then this
is like now suppose like this is where
we currently are it's gone past us right
this is the measurement I get oh 150
degrees so I say oh it's it's now kind
of behind us on our right does that make
sense yes
good questions for you oh yeah do you
wanna do you want to follow that one
yeah with um
so how do you know it's on your right
side you just oh right okay so the way I
know it's on our right side is these
bearings right zero 90 degrees and 108
are all on the right hand side starboard
yeah whereas Port all my angles are from
180 to 270 they're all those larger
angles right does that make sense yeah
perfect okay fantastic question let me
see if you can then say like you knew
what the ship was doing here or whatever
object it was and we created this
but what if you just saw
something
like that
I wonder what you think this might mean
this is the earliest in time right this
is like say
uh four seconds ago and three seconds
ago two seconds ago one second ago and
here is now
what do you think this graph represents
stopped beside us yeah starts with sinus
so where does it stop beside us
on the left there's 270 degrees this is
absolutely one of the possibilities is
it the only one might still be going uh
at 270 degrees 270 degrees is a
direction isn't it on this graph we
don't actually know anything about
distance so this could be something
that's actually
on a collision course with us it's
almost like hold on this is sort of on
on this side they've found us and now
they're headed our way this could be a
real course for alarm make sense
okay fantastic so this is how passive
sonar works it's just listening out for
what's around us and how movements are
happening but today
you're actually going to be doing
something called active sonar now active
sonar is sort of what a lot of us
associate with this idea of how sonar
works it's how bats do things it's how
Dolphins also can hear and know what's
going on underwater you might have heard
of this word
echolocation have you heard that word
before now what's great about this word
it's very messy sorry about that is that
it's
exactly what it sounds like literally
it's using Echoes right so you as the
bat dolphin submarine you send a sound
out
you listen for the Echo and that's how
you know where something is okay now in
order to say okay how far is something
this is all that direction okay you need
to know a little bit about calculating
the speed of sound now I'm going to do a
little test with you and don't worry
there's no um there's no penalty here
for getting a wrong answer but I just
want to see what your instincts are okay
the speed of sound in air
it can vary and I'll get to why in a
second but it's very very approximately
350 meters per second it's pretty quick
right
at 350 meters per second is usually
around what it is in air but in water
it's different
in water
I'm going to give you a moment to think
for a second again it can vary I'm just
going to ask you for a rough
approximation here but just think for a
moment and it is going to be chaotic but
I don't want anyone to spoil each
other's answers I'm going to count down
to three two one and then I'm just going
to ask you all to say aloud just what
your guess is it's not 350 I'll tell you
that for free you're welcome okay
do you think it's faster do you think
it's slower how much faster how much
slower
have a thing do you have a just a guess
or an estimate in your mind
are you ready okay I'm going to count
down to three two one
I don't think anyone said the same
number can we just for the sake of
hearing it clearly Sophia what did you
say 160. 160 Ella I said like 400 400. I
said like 150 150. I went Laura what
200. 200 dig in 200 what 340 340 okay so
very similar all right now
I've got good news for you which is that
you're all wrong now you might say Eddie
that's so mean why are you happy that
we're all wrong and the answer is when
you get something wrong you're about to
learn something now Ella what was your
answer again 400. so I if I'm not
mistaken you're the only one who said it
went higher five star
which is right
sound goes through water faster than it
goes through air however your like size
wise quantity wise you're pretty far off
so don't worry don't feel too bad okay
it can change you again in a second why
but very roughly speaking
it's about
1500 meters per second okay now like I
said we're gonna learn something right
what is sound sound is a wave that
passes through a medium like the air
right so if you ever think about the air
you've got all these little air
particles hanging around
and a sound comes and vibrates all of
these together okay and obviously
they're a little more close together
like this but for illustration the
further apart these things are Imagine
they're kind of like dominoes pushing up
against each other the further apart
they are like the more time it takes for
the vibration from one particle to go to
the next to go to the next and so on
does that make sense now is water more
dense or less than air it's clearly more
which is why there's a weird Instinct
that happens you're like if I was moving
if I was moving through water I'd slow
down because water is much more closely
packed together all of those particles
are right up against each other right
which slows you down when you move
but when that sound goes can you see
it's like a whole bunch of dominoes all
jammed up together in fact if you
literally had a bunch of dominoes
and they were right next to each other
can you see if you push the first one if
they're right up against each other the
last one will move
immediately like there's no Gap but you
don't have to wait for one to fall and
then the next one to fall and so on and
that's what accounts for it being so
fast okay so still a quick test right
again it's active you send out a sound
and you listen back let's just suppose
here's you
and you know there's what we call a
contact somewhere ahead of you and you
just want to know you already know what
direction it is but you want to know how
far it is
you send out a sound
one second passes and then you hear
an echo
this is how fast sound travels roughly
underwater
how far away is the contact
s
ah so instincts here is tricky right
let's think about how the echo works the
sound goes from you
hits the contact and then it comes back
now you heard that Echo one second later
right there's two parts to the journey
aren't there there's the going out and
then there's the return and that's all
in that one second so if there's two
parts how long does each part of the
journey take
half a second
half a second this way
half a second this way and so if we
travel that 1 500 meters per whole
second 750 it'll be 750 meters away at
least that's our estimate okay now let's
see what happens again now we've made
this one ping and then we hear from that
same pin another Echo half a second
later
so the total time between ping and
hearing is one and a half seconds
how far is this object going to be now
have a think
we can do the calculations together
right you already know from one second
you halved it yeah so half of
1.5 seconds is
0.75 and then you multiply that by our
speed wouldn't you okay now if I did my
numbers right I think that's about 1.1
kilometers does that sound like a
reasonable kind of conclusion to draw
except it might not be
because
there's a sea floor that you have to
interact with right and that sound
didn't just go in a direct straight line
it went everywhere so that reflection
that you just heard might have been off
the sea floor to the contact
and back to you half a second half a
second half a second can you see
how complicated the geometry is that
every sub Manor is doing to try and work
out where are things how far are they
where are they isn't it amazing how
mathematics literally lets us see
now just to conclude I did say before
this is roughly the speeding air this is
roughly the speed in water but they can
change we already know it's about
density right what kinds of things might
change the density of the water that
you're in can you give me any
suggestions temperature temperature if
it's hot or cold
what does that do to the density if it's
hot for example which one of these
situations is it
hot water
it's all kind of jiggling around that's
what heat is actually so it's further
apart so in warmer water sound doesn't
travel as fast
um what else might do it salinity it's
fantastic if there's more salt in the
water again that's making it more dense
it'll travel faster there's one last one
submarine isn't just like hovering
always at the surface right it's going
to go
and there's going to be pressure
difference and pressure again means more
density and so all of these things are
taken to it into account it might be
1500 meters somewhere it might be 1600s
elsewhere and these are the kinds of
things that you need to have a think
about as you're navigating and trying to
avoid obstacles
to succeed in this challenge which is
all about sonar we want to think about
the different principles here in passive
sonar which helps us understand bearings
and direction in active sonar which uses
echolocation to understand the speed of
sound underwater and how it can tell us
the distance to different objects this
is how you're going to avoid obstacles
and safely navigate your path through
good luck so we go through the area
opening and
well we then hit a dead end a really
long dead end that takes about six turns
to get out of
foreign